a cosa pensate quando pensate a
inquinamento È una domanda retorica lo
so insomma spiagge piene di plastica
fiumi
contaminati nubi di fabbriche ora
Provate a immaginare emissioni di
CO2 probabilmente non vedete nulla di
fatto la CO2 è invisibile E questo forse
è il fatto che è diventato un problema
ne abbiamo fatta troppa prodotta troppa
e non ce ne siamo
accorti io mi occupo di immagini e
quindi potete immaginare un po' la mia
difficoltà quando qualche mese fa ho
ricevuto dalla mia editor National
Geographic una mail che diceva CO2 How
we solve it CO2 come la risolviamo Beh
per me il problema era di doppio
significato da un lato era come facciamo
a risolvere il problema del CO2
nell'atmosfera sfera ma dall'altro era
come facciamo a raccontare una storia
che non si vede con le
foto Un po' complicato Ecco io un tempo
dicevo che in fotografia documentaria Se
volete fotografare degli Angeli e
siccome Angeli veri nessuno li ha mai
visti ve li li potete solo evocare E
così ho tentato di fare la stessa cosa D
la CO2 non potendo fotografarla
realmente sono andato in giro un po' a
raccontare e documentare quelle che sono
le soluzioni e le tecnologie che sono
state messa in campo per tentare di
ridurre il problema e così l'anno scorso
ho cominciato questo mio viaggio in
Islanda questo bellissimo paesaggio ed è
lì che vi voglio cominciare a portare
perché c'è una cosa EC citan tisa che vi
vorrei far vedere questo fantastico
condizionatore gigante in realtà
potrebbe essere il futuro della
soluzione di aspirare la CO2
direttamente dall'aria lo so sembra
brutto però raccoglie 40.000 tonnellate
di CO2 ogni anno direttamente dall'aria
sembra un numero piccolissimo rispetto
Ret ai 34 miliardi di tonnellate però se
Cominciate a immaginare che tanti di
questi impianti possono essere
distribuiti sul pianeta nell'arco degli
anni forse potrebbe essere l'inizio di
una soluzione Ora io per fare questa
foto qui Vi garantisco Non era
esattamente così utilizzo degli
stratagemmi tecnologici anche io quindi
faccio una piccola digressione
fotografica qui Vi faccio vedere come in
realtà abbiamo usato insieme ai miei
assistenti che sono qui da qualche parte
un delle luci installate su un drone per
illuminare queste strutture in qualche
modo anche il paesaggio ma ora a parte
la digressione fotografica voi vi
chiederete la CO2 una volta che
l'abbiamo catturata Dove la mettiamo Beh
una delle soluzioni migliori come tutti
i problemi è metterli sotto il tappeto
Cioè In realtà nel caso nostro nelle
profondità del della nostra terra Questo
è quello che fa una società che si
chiama clim Fix una società cons sorella
di Carbon clim work che usa questi glue
per olare la CO2 e l'acqua geotermica
che proviene Da una vicina centrale li
mischia come in un distributore di
bibite però anziché farvelo bere Lo
inietta nella nel sottosuolo basaltico e
qui ci sono due esempi molto tecnica
questa fotografia alla destra Vedete un
carotaggio altro termine tecnico dove
vedete i pori basaltici Mentre
nell'altra parte quelle macchie bianche
in realtà è la CO2 che si è calcificata
e che speriamo rimanga lì per parecchi
anni e così nel suo sottosuolo in
dimensioni un po' più significative
Questa è
una una piattaforma di di trivellazione
nell'artico E questa viene usata
normalmente per estrarre gas e petrolio
invece in questo caso il governo
norvegese che ha imparato molto bene a
fare questa cosa sta sperimentando un
progetto in cui anziché estrarre gas
utilizza le stesse tecnologie per
iniettare co2 questo lo fa a 2700 m di
profondità sotto il livello del mare
dentro dei reservar di acqua dolce che
permetteranno di contenere 1,5 milioni
di CO2 ogni anno tonnellate di CO2 ogni
anno è curiosa la faccenda tra qualche
anno Forse non avremo acqua dolce sulla
superficie terrestre ma avremo un sacco
di acqua minerale nel sottosuono E cosa
Insomma il vantaggio di questa
tecnologia in realtà è che molte delle
aziende che non sono in grado di
sostenere i limiti della stabiliti al
Cop 26 e probabilmente al Cop 27
potranno utilizzare questa tecn
tecnologia E questi depositi per
immagazzinare la CO2 che producono in
eccesso uno dei casi è certamente quella
del cemento forse molti di voi lo sanno
la produzione del cemento è responsabile
dell' 88% delle emissioni di CO2
nell'atmosfera e quindi in realtà è
incoraggiante che c'è un'azienda la
Heidelberg cement un'azienda globale
forse un leader mondiale della
produzione del cemento che ha cominciato
a installare sarà la prima che a
installare un sistema che si chiama CSS
cioè che cattura il la l'emissione di
CO2 direttamente dalla produzione e poi
le infila nei depositi di cui vi
parlavamo prima
ora diciamo che molte di queste
tecnologie sembrano essere efficaci ma
allo stesso tempo sono un po'
controverse Insomma ci sono associazioni
ambientalisti che sono un po' perplessi
su queste tecnologie che sembrano in
realtà permettere a queste aziende di
continuare a produrre Inquinamento e non
preoccuparsi troppo di quello che fanno
Il problema è che da qualche parte
bisogna pure cominciare e quindi in
realtà è anche abbastanza incoraggiante
alla fine che un'azienda come la drax
che è la più grande centrale energetica
in Inghilterra ha convertito il carbone
con della biomassa e a questa biomassa
ha installato un nuovo sistema che
permette di ridurre le emissioni di
CO2 e poi c'è la scienza perché è vero
che ci sono tanti sistemi naturali
Qualcuno dice che basterebbe piantare
degli alberi in realtà non è vero anche
a coprire completamente che la
superficie terrestre non saremmo in
grado di recuperare al danno che abbiamo
fatto un'altra soluzione sono gli oceani
in questo caso si parla di tecnologie
geoingegneria scienziati cercano di
capire cosa succede a dei microorganismi
monocellulari che sono alla base della
nostra catena alimentare Cosa succede se
immettiamo dei minerali che permettono
di variare l'acidità dell'oceano e
quindi assorbire più CO2 però questi
microrganismi potrebbero deperire o
potrebbero proliferare dipende da quello
che gli succede la nostra totale catena
alimentare e quindi il nostro ambiente
potrebbe andare in malora Ecco questo è
un po' il ruolo della scienza quello che
cerca di controllare quello che a volte
aziende un po' spregiudicate fanno in
una maniera non troppo efficace ma per
tornare alle aziende forse Ve lo
ricordate qualche anno fa molti di noi
viaggiavano poco e in quel caso le
emissioni del CO2 sono scese tantissimo
Ecco perché non usavamo aerei e quindi
l'industria Aero Aeronautica in realtà
si sta interrogando sul cercare di
capire Come ridurre queste emissioni e
contribuire Questo è un prototipo che è
stato sviluppato dall'università tud Alf
Olanda e con questa strana forma si
chiama un Flying V dove i passeggeri il
bagaglio e il carburante saranno tutti
inseriti dentro le ali e grazie a questa
aerodinamica E questa tecnologia
permette di ridurre circa il 20% la
ruzione del consumo di combustibile e
quindi ovviamente la CO2 ma il
combustibile da dove potrebbe provenire
Beh dalle alghe anziché venire da Fonte
fossili c'è un'università
in in Germania che sta sviluppando un un
combustibile un carburante che sarà
prodotto dalle alghe Ma c'è qualcosa di
ancora più stupefacente non è un caso
questa specie di satellite che io ho
trovato sul tetto del Politecnico di
Zurigo stesso di imento dove Einstein ha
inventato la teoria della relatività
quindi c'è una speranza questa specie di
satellite in realtà è una raffineria una
raffineria che permette di produrre
carburante e combustibile per gli aerei
o per le macchine accumulando Anzi
convergendo energia solare in questi
specchi attraverso un catalizzatore e
aria produrre benzina ora il costo di
questa cosa qui è ancora 10 volte
superiore a quello che paghiamo per un
normale litro di carburante però se
Einstein è riuscito a fare qualcosa con
le sue teorie bizzarre magari anche
questi nuovi scienziati del Politecnico
Ci riusciranno
insomma i miei viaggi mi hanno portato a
vedere insomma delle tecnologie
abbastanza incredibili e e sorprendenti
e ci dicono che queste tecnologie in
qualche modo possono essere la soluzione
dei nostri problemi ora il problema
delle soluzioni è che prima bisogna
vedere i problemi e poi bisogna trovare
la soluzione e per tanto tempo noi non
ci siamo resi conto che avevamo un
problema ora per risolvere queste
questioni Certamente queste tecnologie
non saranno totalmente sufficienti
nell'immediato e avremo bisogno di
cambiare le nostre abitudini nel mio
lavoro come Forse avete un po' capito mi
trovo spesso a elaborare soluzioni
Creative e raccontare cose che sono
impalpabili se non addirittura
invisibili e mi piace molto questo
aspetto del mia della mia professione
Perché rispecchia una delle doti umane
che più apprezzo l'immaginazione se
l'immaginazione è messa al servizio
della collettività ed è uno sforzo
collettivo Allora si può permettere di
immaginare e vedere cose che che non
vediamo che non siamo capaci di ancora
di prevedere o di utilizzare sono sono
soluzioni che magari non sono ancora
perfette ma sono perfettibili e magari
spesso necessarie Io sono in realtà un
grande sostenitore del compromesso di
emergenza e siccome viviamo in
un'emergenza è anche necessario fare
qualche compromesso
Grazie